foreign
I think the failure you're talking about
is
extremely
um clear and consequential with respect
to the doctors
and I suspect that we can learn
something about how civilization goes
crazy that your point about certainty
where are the doctors now right I don't
think you could be a working
cardiologist or pathologist or
oncologist
or coroner
and not be aware of the huge harm that
we inflicted on ourselves I'm not
talking about code but I'm talking about
vaccine Adverse Events
um I don't think you could be unaware
and so where is the chorus of these
doctors who got it wrong initially and
have now realized that and are standing
up and saying you know it's throughout
my Cardiology Ward it's you can't miss
it right where are those doctors well
there are a couple but it's not a chorus
of them why not and most
among the you know it's more than a
handful but relative to the core of
doctors it's a handful it's a tiny
fraction of doctors most of them don't
have Wards anymore right they've been
relieved of Duty oh that's not who I'm
talking about you're right that's a tiny
number the dissidence yeah came out who
initially said hey wait a second what
I'm seeing it doesn't add up what the
claims don't add up I'm seeing stuff
that's not being discussed there's a
system that catches these Adverse Events
we're not monitoring it those doctors
stood up and it was a handful and they
largely and are continuing to lose their
positions their editorships
Etc
um I'm talking about doctors who
presumably did what they thought was
right at the beginning said what they
thought was true at the beginning now
have incontrovertible evidence in front
of them and are not standing up now
that's the thing and there are a couple
who have right there are a couple
um some of them have gone halfway which
confuses me once you've seen what this
what's the halfway what's a halfway
position oh a halfway position is uh yes
these Adverse Events are very serious
but there is no uh early treatment
option you know there are no repurposed
drugs that are worth
consideration so the vaccines are still
the right choice or in some cases in
some cases you get a partial like you
know for many people they don't make
sense but which I don't think is true
yeah anymore well I mean most most
scientific articles about anything
having to do with uh with vaccine
Adverse Events still have to start I
mean it's you could just see the like
Guillotine over these guys the
researchers heads like you you were told
by the editor of the journal that you
were not able to put you were not going
to be allowed to publish any results
that in any way show Adverse Events
unless you basically bracket your
article with yeah but they're awesome
still it's the best way to avoid covid
yep and I mean I think actually bmj uh
British medical journal is a very
interesting exception that's emerging
the editor of bmj turns out to be I
think the reason that we've seen so many
interesting op-eds and some research
being published there and only there
among the major journals right and which
tells you something the the
arbitrariness of you have some journal
in which uh author after author is
saying the same thing and the point is
well you know under a different editor
but that journal have a radically
different perspective even with the same
pool of readership and researchers who
use that journal editors are powerful
not just you know it's not just for
literature right it's this is the
scientific there's a reason they call it
the scientific literature because there
is someone who is effectively not just
it's not
you know if I want to go here but come
sort of Midwife gets applied in a lot of
places where it has no place yeah and
it's you know like how could you object
to Midwife it's like no actually
sometimes what you're doing is helping
create and midwives don't help create
the baby they help ensure that a baby
ends up in the world that was inside a
mother's body and is safe in the world
but the Midwife did not help create the
baby and so editors are doing more than
midwifing oh yeah by a lot and uh and I
think especially in the scientific realm
those who aren't in science have this
very strange cartoonish version of how
it is that we come to know what we come
to know and that's part of why you can
get things like hashtag follow the
science people like oh okay I'll follow
science I guess so that was handed down
by science God yeah and you know it's
exactly that kind of cartoonish Vision
so yes if the editor of a journal
changes can the can the journal change
its direction absolutely oh absolutely
and you know and you know what is the
Atlantic today right it's not a
scientific journal it under any
circumstances but the point is that that
used to be an important publication in
which things were hashed out and now
it's effectively a highly politicized
rag that you know still has high
production values and so people still
take it seriously
um but what I wanted to get at with the
doctors is I think the most
brilliant and diabolical move of the
public health authorities
involved getting the doctors to very
publicly speak as one at the very
beginning of the uh vaccine rollout in
other words
the way doctoring is supposed to work
information accumulates clinically right
doctors see patients they if they're any
good they cannot help but notice
patterns and by getting the doctors on
the record
effectively challenging any claim that
there was a pattern of Adverse Events
before that pattern would have come
through their office right by getting
the doctors to do that somehow it made
it very hard for those doctors to
reverse course
and part of the part of the way that was
done
was by giving it to the doctors first
it was by giving it to the doctors and
all the other Health Care Professionals
first and this was you know I had I had
one Doctor Who did end up taking and
being glad that he took the vaccine but
early on he was like what are they doing
why like we can't know why why would you
put the entire Health Care
Forest Workforce at risk with a new
experimental treatment first and you
know I don't know the answer to that but
I do know that one of the side effects
perhaps intentional at least by some was
exactly this now that it's all of you
who've taken it and it's your job to
make sure that everyone else takes it
you have some complaints or what because
you're you're already dosed up yeah
which is not true and actually there's a
uh that's not true uh that you're
already dosed up this is a I think that
this is a
a
intuitive and wrong perspective that has
lots of people failing to realize where
they are in this program in other words
there is a dose dependent relationship
we can see it to some extent already in
the evidence in the data there's a
dose-dependent relationship between
um these especially the MRNA vaccines
and the hazard and therefore the more
you have the more the greater your risk
absolutely and this this works but still
the difference between zero and one is
um rather large right
foreign
[Music]